es
hola que tal un cordial saludo a todos
ustedes y bienvenidos a este castor
cibernético de este viernes primero de
febrero
el primero se acabó el mes de enero en
asia
podemos decir feliz ya no podemos es
bueno entonces como ya se pudieron dar
cuenta aquí en el estudio paloma
martínez león o galán y leonardo ki
mental y bienvenidos a este castor
cibernético los que nos están escuchando
y viendo en este momento allá por
facebook en las dos así que cordial
saludo a todos ustedes y tenemos
invitadas hoy en estudio está con
nosotros
yesenia fuentes y laurent ses sabor
animal del colectivo danza descalza qué
el primer la primera información que
tuvimos sobre ese nombre el nombre en
esta época está frío
bajo cero
al mínimo la temperatura no ósea pero la
sensación térmica es muchísimo más baja
entonces pues con ellas vamos a hablar
un poquito más tarde sobre este
colectivo danza descalza bienvenida
sanamente y gracias y bien entonces un
caluroso saludo a todos y todas pero
antes de darle rienda suelta a este
castor mensajero cibernético y café
américa no vamos a ver si ustedes tienen
algo alguna noticia o algo insólito que
quieran resaltar antes de lanzarnos con
nuestro castor no la locura del clima en
serio o sea aquí y en lo que pasará
sonidos de eeuu 50 sacrificar un montón
de animales porque estaba con el valor y
al borde de la desnutrición por falta de
digamos de hidratación estaban
completamente deshidratados casi casi
desnutridos y para evitar el sufrimiento
tuvieron que sacrificar los es la locura
de los extremos aquí un frío increíble
en el centro oeste de eeuu 50 55 grados
bajos cero de temperatura más pareja y 2
celsius estamos acá en el sistema pero
los medios estadounidenses decían menos
50 menos 60 y me pregunte si estaban
diciendo
celsius para ocasionar la muerte de
tanta gente yo creo que son preparados
pero igual esa zona suele tener climas
marlene exacto chicago hace un par de
años atrás se había congelado el río y
había una movida el viento había sacado
con una especie de ola y queda una pared
uno no podía entrar no podía ver el río
porque había una pared de hielo eso pasó
hace 34 años atrás ahora lo que llama la
atención generalmente cuando sucede son
eeuu que estos medios internacionales
siempre están hablando y reflejando ese
frío intenso en estados unidos cuando en
canadá es la norma no tenemos esos fríos
nacional parece que nos sorprende porque
saben que canadá es un país del ártico y
físicamente igual yo creo que en eeuu
sorprende porque hay muertos
paraliza todo el país porque no no están
preparados y no tienen todos los equipos
que se tienen acá para levantar la nieve
cuando nieva
40 centímetros de nieve entonces pesaba
en eeuu habían escucho una radio que
pasa programa eeuu que recomendaba en la
zona oeste no respirar profundamente por
la nariz estando afuera porque había
posibilidad de congelamiento de alveolos
porque ya no estás respirando y diriges
y se crea una especie de humedad no hay
como una especie de humedad que se crea
y eso te puede se puede hasta la ropa se
puede congelar o sea bueno yo vi un
reportaje en el periódico mexicano el
universal en el que hablaban justamente
de que toronto que es una ciudad que
vive eso constantemente estos fríos
un poco que estaba riendo de otras
ciudades estadounidenses porque la gente
es parte de nuestra normalidad bueno
para américa pero aparte del frío algo
insólito
[Risas]
leonora hizo una noticia al respecto es
sobre este esta entrada en vigor de la
del nuevo formulario para patrocinar
patrocinarnos de distinción apadrinar
perdón apadrinar abuelos y a padres de
ciudadanos canadienses viviendo en el
extranjero entonces se abrió una nueva
temporada para que los ciudadanos
canadiense que tengan abuelos o padres
en el extranjero traten de hacerlos
venir en el centro del programa de
reunificación familiar y lo particular y
lo novedoso y lo impresionante de este
de este fenómeno fue que el mar el lunes
cuando se abrió la la convocatoria a las
12 en punto el formulario
del día el formulario no estaba
disponible en cuanto lo pusieron
disponible 1 o 2
después duro disponible 3 minutos y
después de 3 minutos todas las
solicitudes inagotables se agotaron
entonces claro el sistema está siendo
cuestionado duramente porque en realidad
no permitió a nadie que no tuviera
digamos ya toda la información necesaria
tener la oportunidad de llenar la
solicitud de enviarla con tiempo y que
después se analice su caso como como tal
entonces ahí hay bastante hay una
petición o una petición para que se
elimine estas esta convocatoria y se
vuelva a iniciar el proceso porque dicen
que no fue válida
es muy difícil que suceda pues lo vienen
planificando desde hace muchísimo tiempo
lo que decía también el gobierno de
canadá es que hubo 100.000 solicitudes
en esos 11 minutos
dicen que duró el proceso me parece no
sé a lo mejor me equivoco en mi
apreciación pero creo que hay un
problema en a nivel canadiense en lo que
respecta a la planificación del tiempo y
de las operaciones que están que están
preparando porque eso fue lo que sucedió
con la legalización de la marihuana se
legalizó se abrieron las tiendas y ahora
no hay ti y ahora pues está haber un
problema que se va a prolongar en el
tiempo sigue volviendo al tema de la
inmigración acá en quebec también está
sucediendo lo mismo es decir tienen no
con los padres sino simplemente gente
que postuló para la inmigración y que
tienen atrasos no sé de cuántos años
pero había como treinta y pico de mil de
solicitudes que todavía no habían sido
tratadas y que eso va a llevar muchísimo
tiempo entonces y hay un problema y hay
un problema y en realidad lo que es lo
que le criticaba en el gobierno cada día
es en el caso del de la apadrina miento
de padres y abuelos es que por qué no
pusieron disponible el formulario que la
gente pudiera verlo ver lo que hacía
falta que para llenarlo y entonces en un
momento dado decir que ahora sí envíen
lo y entonces el envío era como más
justo pero si la gente tenía que ver el
formulario llenarlo y enviarlo en él
y muy corto de tiempo era como un poco
injusto para la gente que no es hábil
con el internet porque todo es por
internet
y dependiendo del lugar donde se
encuentre porque a veces las conexiones
internet no son tan veloces no son tan
rápidas como las de acá entonces pues el
tiempo del que disponen o no más bueno
alcanza bueno entonces si yo había algo
que me pareció muy curioso y gracioso
porque fue un robo un robo ustedes
conocen la fábrica bayón que prepara
para los pastelitos los bizcochitos
estos de todo tipo hubo un robo y se
robaron una cantidad enorme
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hay dos sospechosos de una mujer de 18
años y un hombre de 53 años que fueron
detenidos con respecto a ese robo para
sus nietos y para sus apps entonces eso
sucedió el 14
el de 50 estaba tratando de conquistar
la elijo te regalo esto y le dio 2
toneladas en papelitos está saliendo el
salvar la vida es decir me parece
curioso no las ideas a veces que tienen
los que van a preparar un robo sí bueno
pero nuestro amigo y colega louis nos
contó que en su barrio ser que su barrio
que vive en la afip sur de la isla de
montería en la ribera sur desde la isla
de montreal y si hubo un intento de robo
a mano armada a un camión de caudales
de película en el medio del caudal es
dinero
sí eso sí vale la pena
[Risas]
caramelos no vale la pena si hay
pasteles adentro vale la pena el
esfuerzo la logística del robo toda la
planificación todo el esfuerzo me
imagino que no es más peligroso que el
otro también el dinero no es para vender
22 toneladas en el jardín y queda
congelado y lo entiendo de paz
y regresamos a nuestro castor
cibernético de este viernes primero de
febrero les decíamos a ustedes allá ahí
tenemos algún comentario particularmente
maría herrera dice con alegría
compartiendo con ustedes los temas qué
diferencia dicen san luis argentina con
temperaturas altísimas y en el norte
argentino con inundaciones gracias por
permitirme escucharlos y verlos dice
maría barreda muy bien en la argentina
no diseñar gigante y bueno entonces
regresamos a nuestras invitadas
yesenia fuentes y los onces a buren del
colectivo danza descalza háblenos un
poquitito de de ese colectivo desde
cuándo existe el danza descalza
hola a todos de nuevo hola a nuestros
qué privilegio poder estar acá y está
como como miembro del colectivo de danza
descalza hace cuánto existe y existe
desde desde desde desde que nacimos yo
creo ahí había el encuentro que hubo con
con mis compañeros en ese tiempo te
estoy hablando de 2008 un grupo de
artistas latinoamericanos que nos
encontramos y queríamos bailar y tocar
música juntos incluso como una cuestión
de amigos y ya después los talleres
empezaron 2009 nos empezamos a querer
que quisimos estructurar un poco nuestra
manera de compartir y abrirnos a más
gente y ya se empezaron a empezamos a
invitar amigos y agentes que vinieran a
nuestros talleres y bueno pero lo
hacíamos de una manera muy natural muy
esporádica no sin ninguna pretensión de
de llegar a algún lado solo
hacerlo el placer de poder bailar lo que
nos gusta y tocar música juntos y ya
después el colectivo siguió tomando
fuerza fue tomando más seriedad que nos
cuenta nos dimos cuenta que en realidad
estaba creando un impacto muy importante
para nosotros como artistas y
latinoamericanos en montreal y claro
está la gente que está alrededor de
nosotros y ya y ya fue como te estoy
hablando el tiempo va pasando en 2014 yo
creo ya andrea niño que ya tuvimos
porque antes éramos nómadas si dudamos
los damos los los periodos los talleres
en diferentes partes no en blogs en
bares y ya en 2014
andrea niño estableció con un estudio no
gracias a ella claro con la ayuda de
otros de otros amigos de tus compañeros
pero pudimos tener de verdad un espacio
que lo podemos dedicar a la danza
y ahí es cuando realmente toma una
estructura muy fuerte laurent sabrán se
incluyó entre nuestra nuestra locura los
miembros cambiaron y al día de hoy como
pueden saberlo somos tres miembros
principales que se andrea lo harán si yo
las que queremos seguir con esta con
esta bola añade que la crecen de una
manera magnífica y se dirige a todo el
público en general no sólo a
latinoamericanos sino que hay gente de
todo el mundo son estrictamente latinos
a ver
[Risas]
y pues estamos haciendo talleres que no
solamente son de danza colombiana es es
un mezclo realmente es un intercambio
entre nosotros y también la gente que
vienen así la gente son personas de
todos los lados no tienen que estar
bailarín o nada no solamente interés por
la música y querer bailar si interés
para como experiencia no experience a
experimentar
y pues estamos como en este momento
tenemos el espacio de los talleres que
estamos haciendo una parte que es más
danza contemporánea así que es más como
una exploración juntas porque tenemos
los tres background de danza que no
solamente es de tradición no de
ecológica popular sí y hay una parte que
es más como ir en los pasos y aprender
juntas
a hacerlo de manera diferente así que no
es tradición es una cosa otra tienen que
venir
y para experimentarlo y también tenemos
como performance shows tenemos ahora un
choque se llama aquí que estamos
haciendo por todos los partes es un
choque es por los espacios públicos y
eso es realmente como para todos en
invierno la pregunta es la pregunta del
millón y las encuestas tenemos un vídeo
tenemos la respuesta porque honestamente
no no no no conocía el grupo y resulta
de que ustedes pusieron en las redes
sociales en facebook un vídeo corto que
cuando lo vi a mí me pareció
completamente una locura porque yo nunca
voy a hacer lo que vamos a ver mismo
vamos a pasar el vídeo leonardo y así
después entonces les explicamos a
nuestros oyentes en qué consiste la
locura
la muerte en invierno no sé qué
temperatura llegue ese momento menos 37
127 allí
[Música]
e
y
[Música]
lo que yo quiero llamar la atención es
que gracias a la naturaleza no es tan
descalzas
realmente si hacen real honor al grupo
danza descalza y están descalzos en esas
condiciones no sé si harían un segundo
baile y qué pasó que hay cuatro mujeres
y un solo hombre porque lo más valiente
en las mujeres
es más que fue una idea de la hora y yo
como estábamos hablando y ella hace un
tipo de respiración y no sé cómo se
llama este tipo de respiración pero
tienes que ir en el agua fría y mehdi
como así te estoy haciendo esta cosa y
ella me dice cómo hay podemos bailar
bailar como al exterior
es así porque no pero fue una cosa común
de 12 días así que solamente espontánea
si no sigue y solamente el chico es su
novio yo le dijo te vienes o nos
cortamos y realmente no fue como ahí
vamos a dirigir quien viene solamente
como esta movimiento juntas también el
imán ser también vives en mi casa así
como hay chicas y lo hacemos de una
manera muy bueno yo creo que ese fue un
golpe magistral para la salsa descansa
[Risas]
descalza porque ha habido mucha mucha
visión a miento sano para ese vídeo no
la promoción para él para el colectivo
claro que sí que es el motor que nos
lleva a hacerlo
para promover el colectivo y lo que
hacemos y algo muy bonito de lo que
hacemos es eso que nos interesa poner a
nuestro cuerpo en circunstancias donde
está bien que estamos bien no que
estamos bien que sabemos porque hay un
hay mucho hay una respuesta a no yo no
yo no bailo yo no sé bailar yo no hago
eso entonces nosotros creemos que todo
el mundo tiene la capacidad de bailar y
bueno y digo esto es porque cuando la
hora pues la hora inicialmente empezó a
postear estos vídeos la hora quién es
laura agudelo es no la hemos mencionado
ella es una participante del se ha
abierto y bastante gente alrededor de
todo este de todo este movimiento y
bueno y dentro de nuestros clases como
estaba diciendo
laurent nosotros trabajamos la danza
contemporánea la danza tradicional pero
también hay una necesidad de traer como
como estos tipos de respiraciones de
maneras de sentirnos bien de maneras de
a compañía
de intercambiar conocimiento y por eso
modelo holístico no si al y si entonces
claro está la obra tiene este tipo de
técnicas y nosotros hemos traído otros
tipos
entonces ya teniendo esta confianza del
grupo el estar entonces en el momento
que llega una idea está a nosotros no
nos parece tan tan alocada al contrario
es como claro que lo vamos a hacer es es
magnífico ya sabemos que no hay un miedo
claro que sí hubo una preparación no fue
que llegamos listo y salimos no tuvimos
que calentarnos en antes tuvimos que que
pues yo le llamo una respiración samurai
pero una respiración que de verdad nos
permita en
mantener nuestro chip activo bueno si ya
me estoy metiendo con vocabulario un
poco más complicado pero claro que una
preparación antes de salir a tomar el
vídeo no los taxis y el baile pero creo
que todos tenemos la posibilidad de
hacerlo porque lo vemos idiomas bajas es
muy arriesgado pero si nos preparamos de
antemano todos tenemos la posibilidad
el cuerpo bueno vamos a regresar más
tarde con nuestras invitadas pasemos a
algunos de nuestros comentarios de una
situación
escucha lo que dice van a estar de
saludos desde melo en uruguay dice con
el tema de la marihuana aquí en uruguay
si bien el proceso es diferente pero
cuando se legalizó también hubo
problemas de suministro en las farmacias
en el caso de uruguay se ve se
comercializa en farmacias
particularmente aquí en lugares
específicos
gubernamentales o privadas pero igual el
problema del desabastecimiento fue fue
fue un problema justamente nunca yo no
si tengo un mensaje acá de un comentario
sobre el tema nación indígena de canadá
desarrolla proyecto único de energía
renovable escribe daniela kruger y dice
me parece encomiable que una comunidad
pueda desarrollar semejante proyecto que
además es sostenible loable y la verdad
ojalá hubieran más comunidades que los
invitaran y que en algunos otros países
se liberalizará y se redujeran impuestos
a las energías renovables lo cual me
parece un despropósito un saludo daniela
cruz
muy bien paloma un comentario al
reportaje canal hay su plan de
inmigración 2018 dice de yq sí creo que
es importante permitir a las personas no
profesionales ya que cuentan en muchas
ocasiones con mucho más potencial para
desenvolverse en cualquier actividad un
país no sólo necesita profesionales y
bueno está haciendo referencia al plan
de inmigración en el que se está
queriendo de alguna manera paliar a la
escasez de mano de obra en canadá que no
es nada más para profesionales sino para
más amplia aún muy bien y bueno yo tengo
acá un comentario que viene a propósito
con esto de dan de lanza descalza y la
nieve y es con respecto a un tema que se
llama cuando nieva los lobos modifican
su comportamiento no sé quién hizo esa
noticia tú lo hiciste es que toda
investigación de la universidad de
alberta si mal no recuerdo entonces hay
una cuestión semántica aquí que es el
comentario de j
con respecto al título cuando nieva los
globos modifican su comportamiento él
dice considero que el encabezado está
mal escrito cuando nieva
esa es mi cabeza entonces dice sería
cuando nueva no no ejemplo está nevando
no están llevando a menos que la real
académia lo acepte entonces el proyecto
cuando nievas la palabra es el verbo
correcta el tiempo correcto
exacto sí y yo estuve haciendo una
pequeña una pequeña investigación y
bueno pues cuando tenemos dudas
recurrimos algún canario de duda de los
cursos exacta el diccionario de dudas y
él dice se dice el diccionario de dudas
dice el verbo nevar no admite la forma
nueva
lo correcto es nieva esto se debe a que
nevar es un verbo irregular exacto y
como tal puede emplearse con el sentido
de caer nieve o de poner blanco algo
aplicándole este color o espolvoreando
cosas blancas o sea puedes negar un
entonces el verbo nevar al ser irregular
presenta alteraciones en la conjugación
regular lo que da pie a confusiones como
decir nuevo en lugar de nuevo o nuevas
en lugar de nievas con evans en lugar de
nieve pese a que es una confusión muy
frecuente se considera impropio este uso
por lo que debe evitarse en situaciones
de habla esmerada
conozco gente sobre todo esta discusión
de la tuve conductores venezolanos que
no se conocen entre ellos para ellos es
neva y no hay forma de tener la
explicación explícita pero parece que
hay en ciertos lugares donde uno lo
conoce de la onu
mucho
a veces el problema con él con los
verbos irregulares no en español que eso
es lo que le creo que le complica mucho
la vida las personas que están
aprendiendo el idioma
hay más verbos irregulares que regulares
tengo la impresión entonces pues era
para abundar en el sentido del
comentario de j héctor leonardo y - y
aquí tengo otro mensaje en este caso
dice policía montada de canadá abre sus
puertas a los inmigrantes y lucas
nicolás pérez vivas dice buenas tardes
me gustaría ser parte de la policía
montada de canadá soy argentino tengo 43
años de edad
fui policía y preste servicio de
dirección general de investigaciones
criminales área división protección de
personas y violencia familiar con mucho
gusto me trasladaría a vivir allá los
saludos a la distancia y le decimos a la
lucas nicolás lo que decimos a la gente
cuando hace este tipo de comentarios
y formularios y toda la información
necesaria para no sé si directamente es
una aplicación pero por lo menos para
intentar el trámite de emigrar a canadá
en los sitios de inmigración canadá
usted pone en inmigración canadá en el
buscador que le guste y sale el primer
link de la policía montada pero no creo
que la inmigración sea directa no creo
que porque hable las puertas a los
inmigrantes es decir a la gente que ya
está recibiendo acá así que el primer
paso sería intentar por lo menos el
trámite de inmigración a grasa ya muy
bien leonora tengo acá un comentario
sobre el tema inmigrar y pedir refugio
en canadá no es lo mismo conozcan las
diferencias creo que lo hizo paloma
escribe patricia jancovic y dice ojalá
que todas las personas que requieren
este servicio lo logren ya que no es
nada fácil huir del país que te vio
nacer yo encima tuve el típico ataque de
violencia de género y después de dos
semanas se tuve que seguir a mi esposo y
nadie al esposo y nadie me ayudó
tuve que seguir al esposo dice a él y
espero que si alguna mujer que pase esta
situación entonces dediquen a ayudarla y
no a reportar la porque la agresión no
es culpa de ellos sino del agresor
entonces pido por favor que inmigración
se enfoque muy en serio en estos temas
porque años atrás se portaban a la mujer
con sus criaturas solas y eso es injusto
yo
de hecho una cosa que habrá que
agregarle al artículo y lo podemos poner
a más al día es que después de que lo
presente una nueva política canadiense
en apoyo a las víctimas de violencia
familiar fue lanzada en el caso de las
de los refugios entonces voy a agregar
muy bien entonces pues el complemento de
información vamos a hablar un poco de
los temas y vamos a invitar a nuestros
internautas a nuestros oyentes a ya
escucha veedores
a ver esta semana leonora tú nos hablas
de algo de un estudio de algo que se
asemeja mucho a la epilepsia pero que no
es epilepsia es un estudio conversé con
el doctor que es un neurólogo se llama
josé téllez centeno él es profesor de
medicina en la universidad de
saskatchewan y es considerado uno de los
más grandes especialistas en epilepsia
en el mundo no sólo en canadá él es de
origen mexicano estudio se recibió en
mexico vino a canadá y finalmente está
trabajando acá y es profesor en la
universidad de saskatchewan y él hizo
una investigación con otros médicos
especialistas canadienses donde se habla
de un trastorno que sufrirían más de 70
mil canadienses entonces es un problema
serio que tienen todos los síntomas de
tener epilepsia pero no es epilepsia
entonces le preguntamos al doctor de qué
se trata tiene los síntomas pero no es y
él dice se trata de crisis o eventos no
epilépticos así se les llama
dice estos pacientes pueden tener
episodios de tipo epiléptico que no se
producen por actividad cerebral anormal
como sucede con la epilepsia la crisis
epiléptica es una actividad anormal del
cerebro mientras que en el caso de la no
epiléptica esa actividad no existe y
cuál es el problema son problemas
psicológicos que producen esos síntomas
y el explican por ejemplo y le
preguntamos también cuáles eran bueno
los factores de riesgo que pueden llegar
a producir esos síntomas y él explica
que se trata generalmente de historia de
un trauma físico de abuso sexual de
estrés postraumático cómo viven los
excombatientes también dice que se
asocia mucho con pacientes con problemas
de depresión y trastornos de ansiedad
ahora él también da como ejemplo los
adolescentes tienen esas crisis y qué y
qué son
una vez que se hace el diagnóstico
cuando se lo lleva a un adolescente al
médico y se comprueba que es justamente
una crisis no epiléptica eso
generalmente está asociado
con problemas de acoso y de intimidación
en la escuela así que cuidado cuando los
chicos presentan estos síntomas ahora
también le preguntamos cómo distinguir
una crisis epiléptica de grande no a
idéntica y entonces de aquí de unas
definiciones de muy interesantes que uno
puede pues darse cuenta dice una de las
diferencias más fuertes es que se
refiere a la duración de las crisis las
crisis reales de epilepsia no duran más
de dos minutos es entre un minuto y dos
máximo afortunadamente porque son
terribles y son terribles pero además de
eso se acompaña con incontinencia
urinaria a veces los pacientes se
muerden la lengua eso lo vemos siempre
pierden conocimiento en fin las no
epilépticas son más prolongadas duran
más tiempo no no son son convulsiones
que no son típicas y generalmente cuando
se produce una crisis de esta naturaleza
es ésta está precedida por un gran
estrés del paciente así que eso me
parece que es algo súper importante para
hablarlo
lo que él dice y previene y por eso es
la importancia de esta investigación es
que al no servían bien diagnosticados
les dan los medicamentos
valera y alexia cuando no sos epiléptico
y además eso causa trastornos a veces
irreversibles y hace pues pone mucha
atención con las mujeres embarazadas
pueden los los fetos pueden tener de
alguna manera sufrir las consecuencias
de medicamentos que no son convenientes
entonces eso esa edad es grave por eso
por eso es importante está en esta
investigación y además dice que en los
en los pacientes que no tienen crisis
reales de epilepsia s se empiezan a
tener al consumir medicamentos se
vuelven más lentos para pensar tienen
trastornos de memoria trastornos
hormonales en las mujeres etcétera
etcétera entonces importante ir al sitio
y leer bien lo que explica porque ahí
escuchar la entrevista porque van más
lejos todavía en la entrevista entonces
para más información
rcn
a paloma martínez si yo sigo también con
los médicos y exacto tu red tú hablas
del regreso a canadá de la gripe h1n1
este año la cepa de la gripe que está
circulando en el país en este invierno
es la cepa del h1n1 que causó muchísimas
muertes en méxico particularmente hace
algunos años y bueno esa es la cepa de
este año acá y resulta que llamó la
atención que en diciembre murió una niña
de 2 años en una comunidad en
saskatchewan también en saskatoon
particularmente en un hospital de la
ciudad de saskatoon estaba vacunado no
estaba vacunada y de hecho ese es el
tema que resulta que ahora está los
médicos están diciéndole a los padres
tienen que vacunar a los niños contra la
gripe contra la gripe het hay una
general en general o sea poco importa la
cepa exactamente porque esa vacuna
contra la gripe en general puede
permitir que uno esté más protegido para
cualquier otra se pueda cualquier cepa
de gripe incluyendo la h1n1 que es
bastante peligrosa y que si se y que si
se desarrolla más puede causar la muerte
justa
sobre todo en niños entonces hubo 6
muertes de niños en canadá desde el
inicio de la temporada invernal y todos
esos niños no estaban vacunados
estamos hablando de acción este año a
partir de diciembre de diciembre del
2018 hasta ahora entonces conversé con
la doctora carolyn 4 tran que es
pediatra microbióloga y que estuvo a
cargo de una de una investigación a lo
largo a lo largo y ancho de canadá
porque era miembro más bien presidenta
de la asociación canadiense de
microbiología y de enfermedades
evitables entonces ella dice que hay que
explicarle a la gente que a pesar de
todas las dudas que puedan que puedan
existir con respecto a las vacunas las
vacunas lo siguen siendo la única fuente
de prevenir enfermedades que son que ya
fueron eliminadas de la faz de la tierra
y que no queremos que vuelvan entonces
la gente olvida tiene tendencia a
olvidar y además era mi movimiento en el
mundo con traba contra las vacunas de la
vacuna de la gripe particularmente tiene
algo bastante interesante que es
acumulativa haríamos si yo me vacuno hoy
quizás este año no esté esta cepa pero
para la próxima probablemente de este
cubierto si tengo menos probabilidades
entonces si yo tengo una posibilidad en
diez años o dos posibilidades en diez
años de contraer gripe sin vacunar me si
yo me pongo la vacuna en los próximos 20
años de tener una posibilidad si me
pongo otra vacuna en los próximos 30
años
los niños menores de 5 años tienen que
ser buenos contra la contra la gripe
particularmente a los niños y los bueno
excelente así de que ese punto sea para
que puedan tener más detalles con
respecto a esta esta gripe h1n1 y lo que
hay que hacer
leonardo gimeno tú no aflojas a facebook
porque colabora y hace cosas fantásticas
como por ejemplo dejarnos estar en
facebook live
pero bueno tú hablas tú dices que la
privacidad de los usuarios está
comprometida la compro me como dicen las
malas lenguas por ahí exacto en realidad
empiezo a la forma de este artículo con
la frase de un gran
veedor de nuestro siglo dijo si usted no
quiere que le investigue en la vida
privada no tenga redes sociales no
tengas cuentas en internet o en
deshacerse de este tipo de cosas pero
que con nadie exacto exacto hay que
vivir ermitaño hacer es la única manera
bueno en este caso se descubre
nuevamente que facebook aparte de todo
lo que ya pasó con esto es que tuvo que
comparecer ante el tribunal de eeuu para
justificar y para dar explicaciones del
porqué en este caso parece que
nuevamente facebook con la ayuda de
otras tres empresas ha logrado meterse a
los teléfonos de gente que bueno se mete
por supuesto baje estas aplicaciones o
utilicen de estas aplicaciones dentro de
facebook y recolectan información por
este caso es todo todo lo que yo tengo
dentro de mi teléfono va a parar a las
bases de datos de facebook todavía no se
sabe si fue utilizado o no pero lo que
esto llama la atención porque había
para algunos casos la gente que bajaba
este tipo de aplicaciones se les pagaba
y se les hacía firmar un contrato y un
contrato a los padres hubo padres que
firmaron contratos para que con este año
con el permiso de los padres para poder
tener esta aplicación y antes de eso
bueno facebook tiene todos sus datos
entonces bueno hay en este en este
artículo vemos todo lo que pasó con esta
cuestión y haciendo un repaso de cuáles
fueron los pasos para que facebook
llegara a donde está con estas
aplicaciones y lo que está pasando ahora
que es puntualmente que a los
dispositivos apple
tomó la decisión facetime con la fecha
en messenger y algunas aplicaciones de
whatsapp y aplicaciones viejas de
facebook y apple le dijo basta a
facebook y le sacó en la posibilidad del
permiso de desarrollador
esto implica que cuando uno tiene un
permiso de desarrollador yo desarrollo
la aplicación y la pongo en
funcionamiento
yo no paso por los tests de apoyo en
este caso el facebook va a tener que
hacer el paso que hace cualquier lo que
hicimos nosotros por ejemplo
internacional desarrolló su aplicación y
paso por diez controles diferentes hasta
que apple dijo ok bajo revisión
está bien la ponemos en apple store en
este caso a partir de este momento fue
muy bien poner orden en todo eso porque
con esto de las nuevas tecnologías pues
se permiten todo finalmente con respecto
a nuestra información nuestra intimidad
finalmente la privacidad nelson contra
el rincón buenas tardes saludos y ya
colombia barranquilla que está
preparándose para los carnavales nelson
quisiéramos estar allí
en algo para los carnavales y si merece
nos invita
gracias
a bailar de barranquilla yo los invito a
bueno hizo una entrevista esta semana
con el imán bashan jet que con motivo de
este segundo aniversario del atentado a
la mezquita a la gran mezquita de quebec
donde hubo seis muertos y muchos heridos
entonces pues será el segundo
aniversario el 29 de enero y estuve
conversando con él el imán y con
respecto a la islamofobia no o sea
entonces pues si yo le preguntaba y le
decía bueno como a cómo ha evolucionado
esa situación después del atentado en
quebec y cómo ve usted la disfonía la
islamofobia hoy en día a quien que ve
que él dice existe existe y se
manifiesta de muchas formas lo que me
pareció muy curioso esta semana es que
el primer ministro de québec la frase
alegó él dijo así simple y llanamente
que la islamofobia no existe en quebec
eso lo dijo no dijo qué
no se justificaba un día nacional
porque si se justifica porque no existe
en su defensa tengo que decir que esta
mañana salió un comunicado oficial de la
oficina del primer ministro de francia
legó diciendo que no era que lo que él
quería decir es que no había una
islamofobia organizada que no había
células islamofóbicas en quebec
organizadas pero que existía como en
todas partes del mundo personas que eran
y lomo islamófobas y racistas y otras y
otras cosas entonces dijo que rectificó
digamos el tiro pero de entrada si dijo
eso bueno muy bien entonces escuché en
la entrevista con él y manhattan guille
en nuestro sitio internet para tener un
poco más una idea de lo que estamos
hablando acá con respecto al racismo y
la islamofobia el tiempo se va como agua
entre los dedos regresemos a nuestras
invitadas acá de danza de scouts
inyectadas
bien es pronto tienen algunos proyectos
que vengan y estamos con un show un
espectáculo que se llama aquí y tenemos
una beca con camau turn y
así el show va a estar presentado en el
verano porque son es un show para los
espacios públicos que amamos por
interior y exterior pero más lo hacemos
más en el exterior en el afuera en por
el momento y pues si estamos en
residencia para trabajar sobre esta obra
con con el mi er mundial
antes kirchner y estamos también en las
escuelas en este momento en abrir para
hacer dar clases al hospital y ellos
y a los que quieran ir a bailar a la
danza de calzar todos los martes hay una
lección de vida fría y estamos todos los
martes desde el interior no porque no le
vamos a hacer
[Risas]
descalzo es en el estudio de 325 en las
54 45 caspe estudio 325 todos los martes
de siete y media a ocho y media de la
noche nueve y medio
tenemos músicos live o sea que es la
música música en vivo y bueno ahí
estamos y ahí los esperamos y para
grandes pequeños y tienen una página
facebook su poco para la gente que nos
escucha fuera del canal en facebook
danza descalza y tenemos web en la
página y no el grupo en facebook
un sitio web
entonces agradecemos mucho la visita de
laurent cis de yesenia aquí al estudio
del castor cibernético muchas gracias y
que bailemos más a ver si nos liberamos
de tanta depresión y tanto frío y tantas
enfermedades
con el cuerpo en los controles técnicos
hoy son tan tensos baraka en el estudio
paloma martínez eleonora chamán y
leonardo que menos muchas gracias
gracias y bueno pues eso fue todo
si es entonces que ya saben me abro la
boca ya saben mail son dice nelson dice
están cordialmente invitados a mi casa
en barranquilla hacia una ciudad alegre
y acogedora mucha música baile de
disfraces
bueno eso fue todo por hoy muchísimas
gracias a todos y hasta la semana
próxima vida